- I, as the Snowflake
Consultant on the movie Frozen,
they wanted to get all
the snowflakes right
and so they asked me,
you know, how they grow
and I was very pleased
when the movie came out,
they all looked like real snowflakes,
none of them were eight-sided,
they were all six-sided,
and so, good job.
My name is Ken Libbrecht, and
I'm a Professor of Physics
here at Caltech, and I
also grow snowflakes.
Well, I got into physics very early,
and I've been doing that most of my life.
Maybe about 20 years ago
I just got interested
in how crystals grow and
that sort of led me to ice
and to snowflakes, and we
still don't exactly understand
why they look like they
do, so it's kind of fun
to try to think about.
To make a snowflake in the
lab, you start with water
and water vapor and you've
gotta get everything cold
and basically start a crystal growing,
and I'll kind of blow
moist air down onto it,
and it just absorbs
water vapor from the air
and starts to grow and I can
do this on a piece of glass
and so just watch it grow.
I'm the only one that makes
snowflakes like this in the lab.
When you start to look really carefully
at how a snowflake works, you
find you don't understand it
and there's a lot going
on and you dig deeper,
there's more and more stuff
and it's really very
interesting to me in a way.
I love to go out and, sort of, hunt for snowflakes
because these beautiful works of art
are just falling all over
and you pick a few of them up
and photograph them and the rest of them
you just trample on.
At the end of the day,
I'm trying to understand
how atoms and molecules fit
together to form crystals
and by studying snowflakes,
slowly you figure things
out that are, that are useful.
One snowflake at a time.
(chuckles)